this season on Mama June family crisis
hey guys guess what I'm getting married
like you can't even show up for your own
kids and you're worried about wedding
I'm not going we haven't talked to Mama
since our court battle over Alana's
child support you want to fix it now
because you're getting married no I'll
go to sleep and I'll cry there's things
the world don't know and why should I
forgive her if she's not going to change
her ways we are planning you a bridal
shower the girls are super excited you
lied to my mom it's ridiculous man I
didn't realize I married a flyer Jesus
meanwhile with our two new additions my
priority is my family of seven and it's
a struggle not getting into college
tomorrow go ahead and start the process
you're not even my mama for real wow
Alana's Diva attitude reminds me of Mama
and Jessica's keeping secrets from me
who's texting me it is true I have been
dating someone I just haven't told my
family yet when you get married you're
not gonna tell me you're gonna be like
Jean don't come me to her mama then
asked us for something very unexpected
please help me doctor is thanks
especially do a therapy weekend with
Mama New Beginnings or new endings
everybody may not want to move forward
actions speak louder than words she's
disappointed me so much I do mean
Charlotte I do
the new season of Mama June premieres
Friday May 5th on WE TV stream every
moment Tuesdays and I'll play